hey guys I'm Sharla on Azad today I'm
gonna be talking about why I hate
Assassin's Creed so I'm just gonna
assume that you've all played this one
I'm talking about what happens on the
end of these games because if you have
it like what are you even doing with
your life are you productive what do you
have a job a loser
so imagine Assassin's Creed and I would
dating and I became a little bit too
obsessive at the start of our
relationship I was really really in love
with Assassin's Creed and then
Assassin's Creed started to change and I
kind of started to resent Assassin's
Creed and I eventually broke it off but
not in that like mature way I did it in
like a screw you I hate you now kind of
way and I still anonymously abused
Sasa's Creed on tumblr and stalk
Assassin's Creed Facebook I don't really
do that maybe a little so at the end of
Assassin's Creed 1 you find these glyphs
that subject 16 has left all over the
floor in his own blood in Desmond's room
and there's all these symbols basically
and a lot of them are actual real
symbols that you can find in history
so I spent so much time in ticularly
looking at each of those symbols or what
orders they were placed in if they were
linked together to try and figure out
what all of that meant
then Assassin's Creed 2 came around and
there was even more of that awesome
stuff then the end of Assassin's Creed 2
where you talk to one of the people who
came before and it seems like who was
desmond it's totally one lco sounds like
and then Brotherhood came out and
Brotherhood is actually my favorite game
and franchise I just had the most fun
with Brotherhood I really liked the
renovation system and I don't know I
just thought it was really fun game but
at the end of Brotherhood they kill off
Lucy and while they might have tried to
make it a twist it was just really dumb
because I'm sure most people know that
the voice actor of Lucy was only signed
on for three games and that's why she
died then revelations is kind of where
it all went to crap and I don't know if
it's only me who really loved subject 16
but in Revelations they just killed him
off and he became irrelevant and those
glyphs that I spent hours and hours
looking at and trying to figure out
we're all completely irrelevant
compared to Assassin's Creed 1 and
Assassin's Creed 2 the ending of
Assassin's Creed 3 just doesn't even
matter the ending of that game I pretty
much played through that game solely
just to see where everything was going
to see where it slotted in they came to
the end and I was like I
care not only does this hardly make any
sense I don't care that it doesn't make
sense because it doesn't invite me to
explore it anymore
because I know the next game that's
coming out isn't planned it isn't
necessarily related they just want my
money so it's not that the franchise is
bad it's just the franchise was so so
good and it would have been this
phenomenal thing with an amazingly
in-depth storyline it was so intricate
and thought-provoking and inspiring and
it just seemed like it was really made
with passion and now it's dry and wants
your money Ubisoft have actually been
pretty open about it and said that there
is an ending they have a planned ending
but they've made it very very loose so
they can fit as many games as possible
into that overall story arc and that
kills me inside I can't I don't know any
other franchise it's made me feel that
way I'm sure there are other great
franchises out there but I haven't spent
hours looking at a bunch of goddamn
symbols on the floor in any of them
especially not to have them just
suddenly become completely irrelevant
for no reason without them even
bothering to explain it they just they
discovered it it's just like it wasn't
even there anymore
don't worry a couple of other things
that I did hate about stuffings Creed 3
though like I really didn't use the
tomahawk much I guess because I just um
sort of want to love the hidden light so
much so whenever I equip the hidden
Wade's Connor would just be like hats to
a hard time so I'd be like yeah ready to
kill some [ __ ] and then Connor would
come in and be like what you want to use
tunnel seriously have you seen the
tomahawk have you seen how good it is no
Connor I don't use a goddamn tomahawk
oh but hey let me know what you guys
think in the comments below do you agree
do you disagree why do you love
Assassin's Creed why do you hate it let
me know because I'm always open to hear
some more opinions I'll see you guys
later I mean this right here is my
Assassin's Creed shelf got hidden blade
corner of the back that tomahawk seo seo
seo seo LT Ezio that's actually the
eagle vision heir to it I really like
and it comes with a little eagle so in
case you can't tell I really like South
Korea